successful musician in the classical
repertoire although also jazz and pomp
and he played bass and on the very first
day of first grade at ps11 Queens
Sunnyside Queens now more than 10 years
ago I mean you know like 60 years ago um
60s more than 10 right um I learned the
most important lesson in my life which
is the teacher went around the classroom
asking everybody what their father did
for a living and one kid's father was a
plumber 11 kids photos electrician this
is cleans and I repeat kind of talk like
this and my teacher came and I said my
father was a musician and remember the
teacher saying no no another one hobbies
we're talking about professions I I said
well my father super you mean he gets
paid too many as it actually does yes so
she said oh you mean like weddings and
bar mitzvahs I said well I don't think
he's playing any of those gigs quite a
while since he was like it high school
kitty he he works for NBC's with the NBC
Symphony cuz the Symphony Orchestra
under Arturo Toscanini which was a very
big thing you know there's sunday night
broadcasts in the old radio area no were
like the hottest item on on radio and um
so she was kind of impressed by then and
then she asked me what instrument he
plays and I said base and she said
what's that what do you mean if so I
explain what the base was that it looked
like a violin but it was much much
larger it stood on the floor and
musician stood behind it and she said oh
I know what you told me that's that's
called a cello she said so I tried to
explain the string family to her the
vile in the viola cello in the base and
the reason I knew that wasn't because I
was precocious although I probably was
precocious but it's like the same reason
if the kid whose father was a plumber
knew the difference between a hex wrench
and a pipe wrench and the kid whose
father was electrician maybe knew the
difference between a voltmeter in an
I'm just guessing um well I could see
she didn't like that she said wait a
second it looks like a violin but it's
much better that's called a cello so I
said the smartest thing I've ever said
in my life it's been downhill for me
since that day in nineteen fifty or 51
whenever it was um I said oh okay it's a
cello but I knew it wasn't a cello and I
knew more importantly under two things
one people in positions of authority or
know what they're talking about and what
an authority you know and it to a kid a
six-year-old the first grader on the
first day of school any grown-up is a is
an adult sorry is a any adult is a as an
authority and a teacher is especially an
authority you know an important
authority so here is some this person of
great authority and she doesn't know
what she's talking about she's just
wrong first of all second of all if you
try to enlightenment and tell her the
truth inform her of just simple facts
gets mad at you so from that moment on
I've had a disdain and a kind of
disregard for authority and the irony in
my life is that now I'm in a position of
authority people are afraid to tell me
what they thought of a movie because
they might get it wrong I just came from
the pool i'm obsessive compulsive
swimmer i swim every day and i met
somebody was telling me about a movie
they just saw and I said um how was it
he said it's it's interesting it's
certainly something that you want to see
and I set them I don't think you like
that movie mom my impression is you
didn't like that movie and that you're
afraid to say that to me because I'm a
professor and I know what the good
movies aren't with the bad movies all up
so he says to me you've got to see this
movie um oh what a movie I saw you know
okay but somebody says to me well it
certainly is an important film to see
and you know I just in the inflection of
the tone i can tell that they really
didn't like the movie i can
anything worse to people having to
pretend to like things that they don't
really like and it's been my privilege
my experience over the years because I
travel all around the world wall around
North America and all around the world
teaching screenwriting and giving master
classes and lecturing and consulting
also with film companies and with
National Film development corporations
and so on a various countries I actually
give people permission to admit they've
been pretending to like certain movies
that they really don't like so hence
first-name basis here we're trying to
deport our own authority we want to
support our students as best we can but
we cannot tell them what's right and
what's wrong I give a lot of advice to
students I close give advice to faculty
and who asked me and I not long ago a
teacher came to me and said what a and
he gave this writer notes and she just
ignored them she is it back the new
draft and she hasn't paid any attention
to the notes at all she seems to just
reject these notes and I said to the
instructor I said you want to invest it
in this script I mean so watch you
didn't follow your notes she has the
right to write as badly as she wants if
indeed that's what it is and you can't
have a stake and in someone's script
even though I mean everybody has to go
their own way so that's what we're
trying to do here is have some kind of
overarching structure but at the same
time to maintain the freedom that
artists have to have to to do their art
you